first it was Facebook now it's Twitter
JPMorgan has been winning a prized
position in Tech's biggest IPOs and
there's one banker that keeps showing up
in the spotlight
legendary deal maker Jimmy Lee Lee pulls
out all the stops to win over Silicon
Valley during the Facebook Roadshow Lee
dropped his usual pinstripes for a Mark
Zuckerberg like black sweatshirt with
his name on the back for Twitter Titans
dick Costello and Mike Gupta he made a
point to personally walk them to their
SUVs after a meeting at the bank here's
the thing
Lee's never even tweeted tech or not Lee
is front and center on any deal with
size and stature what makes him so
successful for one there's no banker on
the street that's done more deals to
clients generally like dealing with
someone as senior as Lee someone who
might be able to corral all the bank's
resources three JPM is a big lender and
clients realize they need the bank's
balance sheet so they don't mind letting
JPM have a piece of a deal if it means
keeping the bank happy but most
importantly Lee NAB's big deals because
he has a rolodex most bankers would kill
for as one client described it JP Morgan
needs Lee just as much as Lee needs JP
Morgan it's a deal that works